the latest number of deaths in the UK is
higher than any daily total reported by
either Italy or Spain a very sad reality
indeed but does that mean we'll
ultimately fare worse than those
countries this is how the total number
of deaths around the world have been
rising since the crisis began as you can
see the numbers still growing there but
it's difficult to compare the rate at
which they're rising using these lines
so let's show you that same data and
what we call a logarithmic chart this
essentially allows us to look at the
speed of growth so at first those lines
rise and quite steeply there and in
recent days leveling off a little I just
want to draw your attention to France
it's the pink line there it's the only
European country to have reported more
than a thousand deaths in a day look how
it's now peaking up above Italy there
this matters because our daily jumps are
not far off but there is some hope
amidst a very dark picture because so
far it looks like we're bending our
curves slightly below where Italy is
there and therefore also below where
Frances so from late March till early
April the number of deaths was doubling
every three days if that had continued
we'd be looking at a total of fifteen
thousand deaths at this stage earlier
this week that's slowed to doubling
roughly every four days you can see the
line slightly less steep there and in
the past few days that rate of growth
slowed again to doubling every five days
now politicians say this is good news
but sadly we may still be some way off
the peak of this crisis here are the
numbers of daily deaths that have been
reported that latest figure 980 the
highest yet and if we look at that same
data in a slightly different format
there are some worrying trends the bars
here they represent the number of deaths
and the line there it shows the expected
growth according to the trend since the
start of April because the rate of death
has slowed slightly that line is
shallower than it was but even at that
slower rate we could still be recording
a daily total of a thousand deaths a day
before the end of the
we can't as I said the only other
European country to do that is France we
have to remember that the experts have
said that lockdown would take three
weeks to impact the number of deaths the
next week or so will be crucial